ねばいばい twitter はで飛田尿術た8奈々さんはじめ
チャンネル登録所900万人をてデット奪い隠れパン
隠れないでこんにちははじめ超ですというわけでもうたくさんリブも親の言葉も
いただいております外れ冊を山ネルちゃん冷凍落ち数900万人ですありがとうござい
まーえ
エレがー塗りで水でめでてーな
雨で体カッター
[音楽]
うふ masa
一つ壁を越えましたチャンネル登録者数が900万人突破しましたありがとうござい
ます
今日の19時半ぐらいかなぁペットですね正しく今900万35人でございます本当に
チャンネル登録してくださってる皆様いつもどうぞ見てくださってる皆様
本当にありがとうございます皆さんの一人一人がチャンネル登録ボタンをちゃんと
ポチって押してくれないと
ここまでこれなかったです本当に関節されます
がとうございますもう
昔の気持ちが懐かしいね私はもう100万に行ったらすごいうわぁって感じだったん
ですけども100万人後も10回達成している
ずっと a
いやすごいんですけどどうもここまで来るとですねもうチャンネル登録さする
1000万人にどうしても
いきたいですから行かせてくださいここまで来たら1000万に行きたいもう去っすぐ
に金の再編ボタンの上のなんか
ダイヤモンド再生ボタンれず戻るらしいんですよそれを10場所でを飾ってみんなでお
祝いしたいなと打つと思ってるんですけどもう
1000万人が1つの区切りかなと思っておりまして
1000万に行った際にはウードゥ
この楽しみにしててくださいあの図体発表という大きな発表が待っていると思います
そこまではまずでそこバエをとりあえず全力で走らせていただきたいです
無理します無茶をしますでも楽しんで ok ですよ
ちょっと1000万人まで本当にもやらせてもらえば無茶してでも体を張る賛否両論い
起きるようなこともするし見て笑うための最大限の努力はが貼りつ
道でしっかり集中してチャンネル登録者数1000万に目指したいと思います
もうせませんのない真の話を全部寄せて頂くと本当に心からチャンネル登録者って奇声
マンに行きたいですそういうわけであの改めて皆様
チャンネル登録よろしくお願い致します1000万に言ったらほんとにちょっと重大
発表
あれはる者したいオレの中で本当にしてまでの一つの区切りだと思ってるんでぜひ聞か
せてください
ちなみに僕のいい
体育のなんか素朴調べたんですけども俺の動画見てる人で
チャンネル登録してない人めっちゃくちゃいますめっちゃくちゃいますチャンネル登録
しないと
あの本当にどうぞよろしくお願いますどうかどうかどうかとことかどうかどうかどうか
どうか違うぞ
チャンネル登録よろしくお願いしますあの
本当に思ったよう多くの人がさんネル登録してないまだ伸びしろあるんですごく皆さん
僕もまだまだ頑張ります1000万人までちょっとも捨て身でいこうかなと思ってるん
で
ぜひ皆さんでこういう動画を撮ってほしいとかったらもうにやりますみられてください
900万人のここに来てちょっと初心に帰るはじめこんな下のあった家とはこういう
企画やってと買ったの全部吸収して全部やらせていただきますんで
なぁみたいと思っていることを俺がしたいと思っていると思っ
[音楽]
選んでやらせていただきますのでよろしくお願いしますもうカッコつけずに本当に
チャンネル登録定時制なんだね
ピンピン
をカッコつけずにいますチャンネル登録してください1000万人に行かせてください
よろしくお願いしまーす
それだけが今の僕ローン
描い am
アート結婚もしたいですしこれが始めたと思うんちゃんねる
俺だけだでもうみんなでも盛り上げていければいいなと思っていますよろしくお願い
じゃあ
あっはーるへ行っは